hey y'all movie retrospective time
so this movie right here won the poll
overwhelmingly and i have to say i'm
actually shocked that we hadn't done
this one i thought we did i thought we
had done this one and but then when i
went back and looked at our back catalog
i couldn't find it now we have done a
lot of david cronenberg movies okay we
did videodrome
we did shivers yeah dead zone uh
dead ringers yeah did we do the brood at
the yeah i think we met it in the brood
so we've done like a lot of david
cronenberg movies but for whatever
reason we've never got around to
his kind of his most popular his most
financially successful movie the fly
from 1986. i always forget that this is
a cronenberg flick
maybe because i'm i don't know because i
guess cronenberg is so much seen as more
like any [ __ ] yeah like you know
artistic horror movies and stuff like
that so they don't usually get this is
weird because this is like the kind of
movie
that
is kind of rare because it's one that
was really really popular like with
audiences and i feel like it was really
popular with audiences
even that didn't really that weren't
really into horror movies even though
this is like disgustingly like extreme
like a lot of the gore and like the
effect practical effects in it are
really really gross i remember when this
came out everybody liked it it was a big
hit and yeah it's like
i didn't i never really think of it as a
cronenberg flick because it was just so
mainstream it was kind of like um it was
kind of like uh
jurassic park or something that's a it
was that size of a movie
and usually you know horror movie with
body horror cronenberg types it never
gets that big but this yeah it was huge
which is just kind of a credit to how
how brilliant a film this is and how
everything kind of came together and it
had jeff in it
jeff goldblum yeah yeah he was saucing
too you could tell
all that definition i know he was on the
sauce he looked good though he looked
good in the movie well they kind of had
uh you know they kind of had him bulk up
after he went through the telepod
because uh they wanted him to look like
yeah yeah like he was getting like more
primal because he's like turning it into
a fly or whatever like he went on a
cycle i feel so much better
yeah for a little for a little while but
he's like oh [ __ ] my ears are falling
off
you know not not so good but um
yeah so uh i i'm imagining most people
know i kind of feel like this is uh one
of the movies that's brought up whenever
he talks about oh remakes that were
actually good um you know this and the
thing
but
i don't know i don't know if i would
technically call this a remake
because a lot of differences well okay
well for one thing the original movie
which came out in 1958 which was also
called the fly obviously was based on a
short story uh from 1957 by george
langolin that was in playboy magazine
and the original movie which is fun uh
but you know it's kind of like that
campy late 50s kind of sci-fi um you
know and today it's kind of like you'd
watch and it'd just kind of be like
funny because you know it's a dude with
fly head yeah it's like it's like an
episode of outer limits yeah it's
something like that which like i said
it's it's i like that movie i enjoy it
and actually like the last scene with
like the fly with the little human head
getting eaten by this spider that's
pretty [ __ ] up i mean because i can
imagine like what would that be like
like if that happened to you that'd be
horrifying so it's like you know what i
mean so so it's still a good movie but
the one that they made in the 80s
was completely
kind of rewritten i mean because what
happened was
i guess 20th century fox they own the
rights to the story they own their
rights the original ones so in the 80s
they were kind of kicking around you
know it's you guys remember like from
the if you grew up in the 80s there was
kind of like a thing where they were
taking
sort of like 50s movies and like
remaking them like i said like the thing
the blob stuff like that and like making
them more kind of like high concept gory
or that kind of stuff so the fly was one
that they really wanted to remake
because it was their property
now initially
um it kind of went back and forth they
had a guy named i think his name was
david edward pogue or chris edward pogue
or something like that and he wrote the
initial screenplay
um which was much more based on the
story like the you know the people the
couple at the center were already
husband and wife um stuff like that but
he actually did come up with the idea of
it being a gradual transformation
whereas in the original movie and i
think in the original story um he
basically comes out of the telepod with
a fly hand and a fly head yeah but you
don't know you see it later yeah because
he's right click tries to hide it yeah
um but yeah so the original screenplay
like i said did introduce the idea of a
of a gradual transformation rather than
a sudden one
now they wanted i get mel brooks was
also a producer on this which a lot of
people don't know
it's funny that you you you actually
draw parallels between this and and the
thing yeah and i didn't realize it but
yeah this is carpenter and megan
cronenberg were friends and this is they
they you know they did they played off
one another a lot mentioned each other
in the in the in the movies like they'll
sneak the [ __ ] word cronenberg or
give someone a last name
yeah and um
i can see it now i didn't realize it but
yeah this is cronenberg's version of the
thing yeah his response to [ __ ]
carpenters the thing yeah because the
thing was also kind of like a loose
remake not really a remake but a
re-imagining i don't like it twice as
much but it is a at that same level it
is at that same level oh yeah yeah oh
yeah like i said i don't know if it's my
favorite cronenberg movie because he's
made so many awesome ones
um but i mean this one is amazing and
like i said it you know the fact that it
was so commercially successful yeah and
it's like a really graphic gross like
horror movie you know it's in love the
same way the thing was but the thing
wasn't financially successful makes me
want to see the blob again now the new
the the remake of the block i've been
wanting to rewatch that for a long time
because i remember that that came in
like 88. i remember that being kick-ass
like it was really really thick the
effects were really good mars atta not
mars attacks the [ __ ] the one of the
martians and the kid hispanic by the
marshes i know i like it
not the toby hooper one i think so that
was another 50s remake from around this
time yeah like i said it was kind of
like a trend like a mini trend that was
going on at the time invaders from mars
that's what it was called yeah yeah so
originally i think mel brooks who i said
was one of the producers on this like i
said not a lot of people know that he
was also a producer on david lynch's
elephant man in case you guys didn't
know that which we mentioned on our
review of it a while back
but um he wanted cronenberg
but at the time that they were asking
him about it he was actually working
cronenberg was actually working with
dino de laurentiis on total recall
because he was the original director for
that which now that i know that i'm just
kind of like
now i wanted to see now i want to go
back like in another timeline and see
david cronenberg's total recalculating
like kick ass but uh but yeah so
uh so the so that kind of like fell
through so he so mel brooks was going to
get another director
but then uh cronenberg the [ __ ] with uh
total recall didn't work out they
brought in paul verhoeven or whoever it
was that directed it and so david
cronenberg came on but he said well i'll
direct this movie because like i said i
don't know if you guys know but i i'm
pretty sure
that david cronenberg started out as
like an entomologist i know that right
so or he you know studied it or
something like that
so this was like something that uh that
a project that he was really interested
in doing but he said well i'll come on
and direct it if you let me like rewrite
the script because he liked the some
things about the script but some things
he wanted to change um so he did
actually like change a bunch of stuff uh
you know he made it they that you know
the the scientists and the woman weren't
husband and wife already they just like
met and stuff like that so because he
thought that that would be more
he wanted to bring more uh
sexual dynamics into it you know what i
mean because i was boring the original
one yeah that that's what i mean you had
to have more for the fly to do to do
yeah brenda fly had to be able to do all
kinds of [ __ ] and you needed more people
in the story yeah and he said two women
yeah and he said and he said too that he
wanted um
that he wanted brundle
to be more articulate until later into
the movie because like in the original
movie like he has the fly head and he
can't really talk all that much and then
the original script for this one
um
he kind of like loses his ability to
speak like about two-thirds of the way
through um and david cronenberg said no
he wanted more like emotional resonance
so he's like for that we're gonna have
to be able to like hear him speak like
until the last possible moment it's much
better than the original
oh yeah it's a good movie you know and
you gotta hand it to cronenberg he did
just pull this script out you're talking
about this wasn't descriptive
from the original movie just a very very
basic concept yeah i made a good script
about it yeah i mean the thing about it
and like when the when the movie came
out and like i saw this in the credits
we were watching it last night it's on
hulu by the way
if you want to watch it
um
is that he insisted on his name
being underneath the other screenwriter
because he's like even though they use
most of his ideas he's like well that
guy's scripture he's kind of like the
foundation of it and he's like so i just
changed some things so he said well that
guy should get top correct
so uh so yeah because he was the one
that and he was the one that came up
with the transformation aspect uh yeah
stuff like that speaking of the um the
the the effects are good the practical
effects are really good especially for
the time
i mean the guy that worked on this chris
wallace
he had previously done gremlins
um and he worked on raiders of the lost
ark
and like some others so he was like kind
of a big you know guy like you know
effects guy this movie only cost nine
million dollars to make damn as soon as
i found that out today because we just
watched it like last night and i was
like holy [ __ ] crap like all of those
practical effects it was all puppetry
and all that kind of stuff they pulled
that off with nine million dollars and
then the movie made 60 million which
like i said was like a big i mean for a
graphic horror movie that's like pretty
that's pretty awesome they also came up
with some nifty ideas you know what i
mean the fly being just kind of
blended in with him at a genetic level
you know what i mean and and so he just
had fly dna now and then later on he
gets blended with a damn door of [ __ ]
pod c
that was a weird effect yeah i had
forgotten about that seen the damn door
was open
[ __ ] up so the machine's like oh you
want to fuse that with that okay yeah
that's fair enough that that's a good
idea so you know they're they're pulling
out they're pulling these ideas out
it's good it's good they're thinking
outside the box yeah like what would
happen at the door was though oh yeah
but me and jane were thinking well what
would happen if the damn hair from the
damn monkeys that he was
teleporting what if that was still in
there
well i was what i was watching another
video earlier today that said well what
about all the like microphones and stuff
that would be in there it's like well
you can't think about it too it's just
sci-fi you know what i mean it's like
you know it's just it's it's a story i
was saying it was what happens if
somebody left fingerprints behind and
they're sweating [ __ ] you know
yeah you'd just be the limitation that
would be a limitation of the technology
you'd have to be totally [ __ ]
sanitary yeah it would have to be like
completely sterilized every time you
used it yeah because yeah like i said
what if he would like that baboon had
like left a hair in there and then he
like fuses with the batman the other
thing is is that your body's filled with
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] symbiotes and in
paris yeah that's what this person was
pointing out absolutely
they're like yeah it's like why wouldn't
he have become like e coli man
i guess the computer was able to keep
track of all that yeah that's kind of
what that's kind of like the the thing
that people hand wave away they're like
well he he was smart enough to know that
um you know that he had accounted for
that like in his programming but if he
hadn't accounted for another thing being
in there with him yeah which that's okay
that's fair enough like i said it's
sci-fi you can't think about it too hard
um because it'll be like it starts
falling apart it was like plot holes
everywhere yeah but yeah but i was gonna
say that um yeah there there's special
effects in this
like i said they still look amazing
um it's kind of like there's actually a
couple of sequences in that were
originally in here that were taken out
and i've because uh test audiences did
not respond well to them
what was taken out okay so this one
scene
and this is before
like uh jeff goldblum seth brundle has
gone all the way into fly mode and he's
experimenting with
he's doing his genetic splicing you know
what i mean because you know as toward
the end like him and uh he wants
uh veronica his girlfriend played by
gina davis uh because she's pregnant
with his baby he wants to like fuse them
all together so i guess he's like
testing that
so he puts in
a baboon
and a cat oh that'd be good
and
i mean you can still see it it's in the
deleted scenes they did shoot it
um and so the creature that comes out is
like this [ __ ] up looking like baboon
half baboon half cat hybrid's got like a
cat head sticking out of the house oh so
it's like it's really really horrifying
looking and it attacks him and it wasn't
so much the creature that upset people
but
the the creature attacks him and he
throws it off and then just beats the
[ __ ] out of it like with an iron bar
and um i think audiences thought well
it's not so much the creature it's just
that it makes him less sympathetic right
makes it weird like
because he's like beating this poor like
helpless creature that he made to death
yeah uh so so they took it out uh it's
the what he said he was yeah and the
insects don't have any compassion
yeah so that would have been better to
kind of make him just becoming he's
becoming a monster becoming an insect
i mean i think that i i don't know like
like i've seen the scene because you can
see it on youtube because it's on the
blue ranger it looked good
yeah it looked cool actually it wasn't
big it was kind of like bigger than cat
size but not as big as baboon size which
makes sense i would have made it an even
blend though not just something mashed
together that would have been a cooler
like a baboon thing with a cat face and
cat ears and
claws i'd have made a total totally new
animal because that would support what
he's talking about gene splicing is what
he's talking about yeah so
if it did that if it just mashed them
together physically then that means the
the transporter wouldn't have wouldn't
have worked
to blend him and somebody else so we
just would have mashed them together but
i think by that point he was like so far
gone that he was just like it's
interesting as soon as he found out she
was pregnant he's like oh well maybe
right maybe that'll i don't think he
really thought it was gonna work okay i
mean you know what i mean he was kind of
like getting to the point where he was
just trying to like hang on to the last
shred of his humanity but it was just
like slipping away from you bash a cat
in a baboon together is it a caboon
it's a caboon it's a
[Laughter]
or
caboom
bad cat
that cat
cat the cat but yeah so that was taken
out uh because like i said they thought
it made him less sympathetic which you
know i can see that um the other scene
that was taken out it's interesting too
because this movie is like i don't feel
bad about spoiling this because
everybody has seen this [ __ ] movie
even if you haven't seen it you know the
story yeah of it like you know you know
what happens he invents a teleporter
it turns him into a half man half-life i
think in the original screenplay that
that uh pogue wrote
um i think he basically turned it was
still a trend like a gradual
transformation but he turned into more
like a man-sized fly yeah whereas david
cronenberg wanted something that looked
more
i guess like realistic and more like
this the progression of an actual
disease yeah you know what i mean uh so
he could kind of use that as a metaphor
for like disease or like the aging
process yeah
yeah at the end though he did look like
a man-sized fly he did kind of skinny
yeah they just wanted like more of a
human look to him and they wanted him to
still have like kind of expressive eyes
you could still see that he was in there
yeah it was like a metamorphosis
the fly was inside of it remember and
yeah everything fell off like a shell
yeah once she like reached up and pulled
his jaw off and then it all just like
cracked open he was kind of like
becoming a cocoon yeah it was like that
kind of thing which i think was actually
like a good way to go yeah but uh so
yeah so the end of this where basically
he uh he has enough humanity left to
kind of like lift the the gun up the
rifle up and like put it to his head
like you know shoot me put me out of my
misery and she doesn't want to do it but
then she does finally do it and then it
ends
i actually really liked the way it just
ended abruptly like that you know what i
mean
uh but they did actually shoot a bunch
of different kind of codas to the you
know little endings to it but it's just
when they showed them to different
audiences everybody was like no they
didn't really like it um i think they
liked the impact more of them of her
just like killing him and putting him
out of his misery and then it was the
end because some of the some of the ones
they did like one of the um endings that
they shot
was
her back in bed with her
dick bag ex-boyfriend so they got back
together which people did not like at
all um and she was having a dream or you
didn't know it was a dream at first but
she had a dream that she gave birth to a
baby and it was normal
but then it grew like butterfly wings
yeah which
i don't know like i've seen that ending
too and i'm like that looks a little
silly to me and cronenberg didn't really
like it either and he's just like no
we're not doing that just ending it is a
lot like the way the thing ended that's
what i'm saying so i think that had a
lot more impact
and that was kind of like you know
cronenberg was like you know we shot all
these different endings and stuff and we
tested the different ones with audiences
but he's like i didn't really like any
of them because he's like i really liked
that impact
of just like him being dead and then
like the end it's like they did it
didn't really seem like it took away you
know it kind of like deflated a lot of
the emotional resonance of that moment
when you just had this oh it's kind of a
happy ending like where she ends up back
with this [ __ ] ex-boyfriend of hers
but that's another thing this is really
the only and i don't even know if i'd
call this a criticism
maybe the only slight criticism i have
of this is that
her ex-boyfriend who's also the editor
her editor right like at the magazine
she works at is a giant
gaping anus
um you know what i mean like through the
first half of this movie i mean he's
like not even disguised again he's like
he might as well he's just like a giant
[ __ ] tool
and for him to
i like i like that he had some character
growth in the sense that he almost he
kind of goes on to become a hero like to
help her and stuff
um i think it happened a little bit too
quickly
i have a choice i mean i yeah and
honestly like but i was thinking about
it when i was watching it because like i
said i'm a writer and i think about
these things so i was kind of like well
i guess she could justify it by saying
well he had an ulterior motive because
he wanted her back
and he's like oh your boyfriend's
turning into a fly creature well just
let me help you out with that maybe we
can like kill him and stuff so he was
kind of like so maybe you could argue
that he's still kind of a dick because
he had like ulterior motives for helping
her cost him a hand though
and a foot and a foot that's right i
love that scene honestly because that
guy was like such a [ __ ] and then at the
end like i was like i don't care if
you're like turning around now and like
trying to be a better person it's like
well i guess you could say when jeff
goldblum like barfed on his ankle and
it's like came off
i guess they were just trying to say
that at least he was a human being
yeah and fly didn't have any compassion
once yeah that's what i was going to say
is that in a way like i can see because
it's almost kind of like an inversion
because jeff goldblum's character seth
bro seth rundle it's like he started out
as like a really nice like sensitive
dude and then like after he went through
and got the fly dna he became like a
raging jack wad and he went the other
way and then it went the other way and
then the other way started out as a
raging jack wad and then so it was like
an inversion of character which like i
said he had to suffer to a tone he had
to put his ass on the line and lose a
hand and a foot but then you know he was
a human yeah yeah but a human wouldn't
let wouldn't let that go down a fly
would yeah
because fly don't give a [ __ ] i didn't
give a [ __ ]
flies damn robot
yeah but yeah so that's the only thing
but like i said i've seen a couple
people say that curse but if you look at
it in that light because it's weird i
was watching like i said i've seen this
movie a bunch of times and when i was
watching it again last night i was like
wow that movie seems really short i
guess it's just because one thing i
noticed too about this time of watching
it this movie is very efficient there's
not a single scene in there that is
wasted yeah um it just kind of like it
gets right into the very first scene
is uh seth meeting veronica at that
party and he just immediately says i'm
working on something that'll save the
world or you know change the world and
like then they just immediately get into
it so like every single thing
is kind of building up to this thing and
like i said there's nothing that's
wasted it doesn't meander it's just you
know i don't even remember like what the
running time is but it's because i was
sitting there going man that just flew
by you know what i mean well now that
you mention it man it's just it's a lot
like the thing yeah where it's it's it
draws you in it's very kind of direct
it's it's situational it's showing you
one thing after another there's no like
i said no meandering the edits real
tight
it's not the same kind of setting you
know what i mean like the things
happening
in the art you know down in antarctica
and it looks like you're in the
antarctic it is a really impressive you
know uh
what carpenter did this one is different
it's in an
in an urban setting mostly happening in
apartments and stuff and laboratories
and you know uh but uh and his
laboratory was in his apartment wouldn't
it yeah yeah and he didn't even have an
elevator did it that apartment they had
to walk upstairs yeah it was stairs yeah
because remember he was carrying that
girl like up the stairs tawny was that
character's name but it does make you
feel like you're seeing it happen and
you know what i mean like you're there
it does feel it is does feel grounded in
reality yeah um it does have that 80s
style late 80s style um
it looks good it looks real good
and it's just a
straightforward storytelling that keeps
you in there keeps you it keeps you
grounded in it
and honestly i think that
um jeff goldblum and gina davis who were
a couple in real life at the time uh
actually which i had forgotten about
real good acting yeah um
that that really lends this
a real emotional impact that a lot of
horror movies don't have well you can
see what happened to the to to the
scientists that goldberg is playing
goldblum's playing you're you're
you're kind of like uh
you're watching you're going man what
would that what would that be like if
that was happening to me
yeah yeah it's a tragedy it's
like a tragic story you can identify
with it you're like oh man that would
suck
you know he's vomiting on the [ __ ]
donuts [ __ ] to dissolve them and lap
them back up you do it in front of
people because oh yeah and he's gross
isn't it he's trying to make light of it
yeah but yeah he's me he's trying he's
making light of it because he's
terrified yeah and then he's got a this
hope that he's gonna be able to fix
himself or that it's gonna be okay you
know oh i'm turning in something better
and uh
they turn into a fly that's what i'm
saying i think at first because when he
first goes through like before he
realizes that there was a fly in there
um and he comes out like he said he's
doing like gymnastics and stuff and he's
just like oh my god this is so awesome
and stuff but then like little things
start like he's in the coffee shop with
with veronica and he's like keeps
putting more and more sugar in there and
she's like uh hey you want some coffee
with sugar right there sweating he's
starts sweating out all this milky
grease and [ __ ] you know he's just
going through all these damn hormonal
changes i don't know what that's like
and [ __ ] he just starts becoming real
aggressive feeling good and wanting to
[ __ ] people up and wanting to go after
women and
he's starting to become an animal you
know and he gets more and more
insect-like as he goes
so
and that's what that's what a fly would
be it would be like a robot but it would
have a primitive emotions and drives
it just run fight breed you know lay
eggs just real simple [ __ ] this is great
you know oh i love flying around
look at his turn
got a dead dog this is great
i'm sure everything's great when you're
a fly you know oh it's got me uh
flag is eaten by something and that's
that's their whole life you know yeah
for like however many three days or
however long couple weeks
but they probably just think it's great
and you know that's that's yeah they
don't know any better no real positive
[ __ ]
we're flying around dude yeah it's
awesome
look at the turds
smell them smell a mile away
but that's the thing i kind of feel like
that's what's so great about i mean jeff
goldblum is so [ __ ] great in this and
the two of them are just great in this
and they play off each other so well
but it's kind of like i think the best
thing about his performance is that i
think even from the beginning
he suspects that something went wrong
but he is so trying to convince himself
that this was a good thing
that
you know he would you know what i mean
that he's just like willing to just like
this is so awesome this is so awesome
and then you know then he tries to like
make her go in and she's like [ __ ] no
dude it's like because she can already
see like little things that are
different about him so she knows that
something went wrong he felt good
instantly when he came out of there yeah
but like i said i think he didn't know
what happened though i think like just
like very very soon after he came out he
started to i don't think he knew what it
was but i think he started to suspect
that something was the matter
um because he knew that he was different
but he was kind of like in denial like
trying to you know trying to make
himself feel but oh this is a good thing
i thought about this [ __ ] before if you
had a teleporter like that that would
disassemble all your molecules and then
reassemble reassemble you perfectly
would that be you i don't think it would
be
well like i said watching this i know
this is gonna this is weird but it's
like watching this made me kind of want
to watch um that [ __ ] the the
prestige because that tackles that exact
same question
where you know it's
it's they invented a teleporter nikola
tesla invents a teleporter in that and
um you know and it makes essentially a
clone of you and so he just had to keep
killing the clone like every time he did
the trick
because it was a different person what i
think it would be it probably would
which is like
you would vanish and then it would make
an exact replica
that would feel like it was you it
wouldn't be you though it would be it
would be like a clone of you a perfect
replica it would not be you though yeah
your consciousness wouldn't be in it
it's kind of like
i kind of feel like that concept is sort
of hinted at in here with the stake
right because remember when they put
because he can't figure out like at
first he can't figure out why i can't
why he can't transport like living
tissue only inanimate objects and then
he has the idea to like put a stake
through there yeah and then like in two
pieces and then he cooks it and the one
tastes fine you know the one that didn't
go through obviously but then the other
one she said it tastes synthetic right
almost like the machine made a copy of
it and didn't really know how to make
you know what i mean see essentially
your data yeah you can just reduce a
person to data and then use the data to
take molecules and put put you back
together but the thing is if you have
that data you could put more than one of
you back together
so you could disintegrate one and if you
had the raw materials bill four what are
they gonna be for you
no no one needs more of me no
no no
they'll all think that they're you but
then uh
no they're not you they're [ __ ]
copies
and they might they're going to be alive
they'll probably have their own
consciousness but it's not your
consciousness
because if you could just scan a person
and make a copy out of raw material
you would see a copy of you so that
would not be you yeah you know and if
that thing killed you you would die yeah
there'd be and another one would take
your place that would be freaky yeah so
honestly this whole teleportation [ __ ]
no
no thanks like i said i like i like that
the movie the prestige like went into
that yeah you know what i mean and like
showed what that would actually like to
be like if somebody didn't invent one
i'm not buying it
you know what i'm saying anything that
does like what the star trek transporter
does kills you
yeah so it's like every single time they
go through that kirk gets killed
another kirk pops up it's not the same
kirk it's not the same kirk it's a cop
and they were worried as far as the star
trek lore they were worried about that
but they had proved that no it's not i
ain't buying that either no
that was some hand waving that would
kill you no no it's the same it's the
same
because you wouldn't even have to
transport it
when you think about it yeah yeah i mean
you could just
scan one and make a copy somewhere else
and then kill this one and let that one
live and that's transportation
you just yeah you know you could call
that transportation it wouldn't be it'd
be murder yeah because you're not trans
you're not transporting anybody that one
didn't go anywhere right
right well free-flowing molecules are
not conscious they're not live
as soon as you come apart into molecules
you've been [ __ ] vaporized
yeah you're dead
putting it back together no i ain't
buying that yeah i agree yeah there's no
reason to move those molecules because
those molecules can be had on the other
end you can just assemble them over
there with the ones you got over there's
going to build another one just build
another one right so we don't need that
one [ __ ] that's not realistic it's not
efficient to transport those molecules
across space and reassemble that's a
waste of energy
because it's not going to assemble you
it's good
you've been vaporized
they can [ __ ] play word games all
they want
[Laughter]
ross knows
i know what life is no i i agree with
you yeah
but uh yeah so like i said because this
when this came out amazingly even uh
critics and stuff like that that didn't
normally like horror movies [ __ ]
loved this [ __ ] because they were just
kind of like this is and like i said as
disgusting and over the top as the
effects are and everything well i had a
good script it has good story yeah had a
good story had good characters good
acting um actually even in 1986 they
were talking about uh maybe you know
gina davis and jeff goldblum like being
not nominated for oscars which of course
they were not because it's a horror
movie but uh the guy that did the uh
effects did get an academy award for
this uh and rightfully so because the
effects in this still look revolting to
this day um you know what i mean but uh
yeah so like i said i was gonna say when
this came out in 1986 a lot of people
saw it as because that was kind of like
the height of the aids epidemic so a lot
of people saw it as like a metaphor for
aids and they asked david cronenberg
about that and he's like well yeah if
you've experienced that then yeah you
can totally see it like that he's like i
kind of meant it more as like a
universal like disease or aging but uh
he's like yeah it could totally be aids
because you know anything that's like a
degenerative disease he's like cancer
you know or just the aging process or
whatever that was mostly what he wanted
to do something more like general
now
as most people know there was a sequel
to this the fly two the fly twos
never saw it eric stultz it's not bad it
was actually directed by the guy who did
the special effects on the first film
um so
and all with all of that entails in that
it's a special effects extravaganza like
a showcase which maybe we should see it
nothing wrong with i've seen it like
several times uh they shared it on cable
a lot back in the old days
yeah it's basically eric stoltz plays uh
their seth and veronica's son martin all
right uh and he's kind of like carrying
on the work sort of like it's not par
fly then
uh it goes that way
because i mean you know yeah that's the
yeah he was born normal but i guess
i can't remember
if he like i guess he transports himself
to just like his dad even though he's so
he's like i don't know he didn't learn
from his dad's mistakes i guess but uh
but yeah so a similar kind of thing
happens to him like i said it's not a
bad movie but it's not nearly as awesome
as the first one
um interestingly david cronenberg
himself who is not a big fan of like
making sequels of things
had actually written a treatment for
he's like it's not exactly a sequel but
it's kind of like in the same
vein like it is about the telepods and
it is like about that um
but
he just never and he actually wanted to
make it but he's like well the studio
like wanted it to be low budget and like
the concept that i had needed a bigger
budget and they didn't want to pay for
it and so it kind of just like went back
and forth and jeff goldblum even though
he died in the first one spoiler alert
um
he actually said well if they if he made
another what if cronenberg made another
one i would totally do it because he's
like i really really liked working with
david cronenberg oh that also reminds me
too
the the famous dream sequence where gina
davis gives birth to a big maggot and um
if you didn't know that is actually
david kronenberg being the obstetrician
um he actually didn't really want to do
that he's like i don't usually he he'll
act in other people's movies
he doesn't
yeah he'll act in other people's movies
but he doesn't like because he was in um
night breed i think that clyde barker
movie uh played like the villain in that
but uh he's like i don't really like to
do cameos in my own movies but gina
davis asked him to be the obstetrician
like in that scene she's like because
she felt uncomfortable like with another
actor being there
like it like in between her legs like
with the stirrups and everything so she
asked him to do it so he said he would
do it so i just thought that was like
kind of funny uh they've also done so
yeah so cronenberg he said that he does
have a treatment for a sort of sequel
he's like it's kind of a lateral sequel
in that it's a similar
theme and like a similar story like
telepods transformation stuff like that
but it's not like a a direct sequel
but i don't know if it's ever gonna get
made uh so i don't know they did so so
they have made one sequel which like i
said was okay i remember it being okay
um you know it's not great but it wasn't
terrible i bet you a cronenberg flick
like that coming out now it would do
pretty good it probably would and um you
know honestly because he kind of moved
away from horror uh in his you know
because his more recent films will
recent that they were a long time ago
but he he's kind of gone more into like
a like a violent crime thriller
direction like you know eastern promises
and stuff which are you know amazing
movies but they're not like straight up
horror movies um but you know and his
son
you know brandon is obviously doing uh
already horror movies too like just
which are also awesome they're good from
what we're saying yeah we yeah we've uh
i've seen both of them like both of the
ones that he's made so far and they're
both really good
but uh yeah so i think they did do a
continuation like uh a graphic novel or
something like that oh i think back in
2008 david cronenberg did an opera based
on the fly i've seen like sk it actually
looked kind of cool i mean you know what
i mean it's you know what i mean um but
i don't know i i've seen like clips of
it like on youtube and stuff and it
looks kind of cool but that's i just
thought that was really funny that he
made it into an opera but uh yeah so
anything else we need to say about the
fly nah that's good like i said it's on
hulu uh it's a [ __ ] classic if you
haven't seen it get your ass over there
i mean even people haven't seen it like
i said everybody knows the story because
it's been parodied so many times like
with a person with a fly head and show
like that
but yeah go what it's good yeah you want
to see this one and the thing doesn't
make a good double feature with the
thing actually now that i'm thinking
about it yeah but yeah uh definitely see
it if you haven't it's a classic one of
the best horror films of the 1980s
easily uh you know so yeah go check it
out and that will do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys on
the next one bye